live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality joined today by my co-host
Ramsey personality George Campbell we're
taking your calls today at triple eight
eight two five five two two five give us
a call let's talk about what's going on
in your world all right let's go to the
phones first up we have Jamie calling
from Olympia Washington
hey Jamie welcome to the show
okay thanks for having me hey thanks for
calling how can we help
um I know taxes is around the corner and
I'm almost done paying off my car
um I'm thinking about paying off my card
and uh putting the rest in a high yield
savings account I just I just discovered
those so just wanted to see if that was
a good idea
well do you have any debt
uh just the just the car and then I'm
then I'm done I already paid off my
credit card last year thank goodness
awesome uh what's left on the car
what was the what what's left on the car
loan
uh 3 000. okay how much money do you
have in the bank
uh they took a hit doing some car
repairs so right now I have about seven
hundred dollars in the bank okay and
your what was your question
um with with the taxes I'm thinking I
might get four thousand in tax return
I'm thinking I should just go ahead and
take out that card note and then put the
rest of the savings account or
okay so let's say in April you get a
return of four thousand you've got three
thousand left on the car loan that
leaves you with a thousand and that
would leave you with Seventeen hundred
dollars in the bank correct yeah okay
well that would be my plan is pay off
that debt ASAP
okay just knock it out yeah just knock
it out because the next step in the baby
steps is to build that fully funded
emergency fund so you'll be able to
knock out baby step two pay off all your
debt and then start working to build up
to that three to six months in expenses
so that's pretty exciting and Jamie
here's here's another piece of the
puzzle that I want to challenge you with
could you pay off the car before you get
the tax return and you can use that
towards your emergency fund
um I don't know if I could do it before
what's your income like
um I only make about about 45k a year
okay and all of that money where is it
going are you doing a monthly budget
yeah I'm just now starting the budget I
had it really dial back on eating out
and that that was probably my biggest
one that's the kicker the car yeah the
car repair the eating out was constant
but the car repair hurt we had to like
put 400 into car repairs
um who's winning is there a spouse
yeah okay so what's your total household
income
uh total I would say 60 all together
so your spouse is making about 15 are
they part-time what are they doing
they're they're part-time they only work
three days a week about is there a way
to increase that
um what's holding them back the kids
the kids and they they care to be honest
daycare is just it's just too expensive
but we try to avoid it with our
schedules okay so your spouse stays home
yeah and then for three days
um she does go in it's you know the
later on when I'm home so okay and the
other piece when you get a tax return
here's the issue I have with it you're
giving the government a interest-free
loan all year long with that money so
another goal I have for you is to stop
getting such a large refund and I also
wouldn't Bank on getting a big refund
this year because the with the tax
changes that have come down the pike
they have gotten rid of all the expanded
child tax credit all the expansions that
were you know due to the economic impact
that was happening with the pandemic is
gone and so are you banking on this 4
000 how sure are you it's going to be
that number
uh I'm I'm doing a low low guesstimate
no I think the lowest it will be is is
four thousand it could be three thousand
but I I am pretty sure it'll be around
there okay well I wouldn't plan for it I
would pretend live your life as if this
car debt is is needing to come from your
future income and attack that thing with
a Vengeance even if it means working
overtime Selling Stuff continuing to
slash your expenses uh just in case that
tax refund comes in low and now you're
like oh gosh and now I'm defeated
because I thought I was going to be debt
free
and so that's how I would approach it
and I would also maybe work on changing
your withholdings with your employer to
get closer to zero where you don't owe
anything and you're not refunded much
is that is that the better options of
just to zero it out not to get anything
back and not to pay yes because that
means you paid just the right amount of
taxes instead of paying too much or not
enough if it's not enough you owe money
if it's too much you get the refund
that's how taxes work it's not a gift
from Uncle Sam
okay so I just been paying too much okay
exactly that makes sense and what what
about those uh go ahead no keep going
I was going to ask I just discovered
um Alley Bank so Ally yes
and those those are scams are there no
no those are legitimate Banks Here's the
the magic word you want to see on any of
these websites is FDIC and that is
federal insurance that backs that bank
in case they go under your money is
protected up to 250 000 per person on
the account
okay and so allies a legitimate bank
there's a lot of other high-yield
savings accounts out there the ones you
don't want to go with is the ones that
have credit card companies attached to
it because what that really means is
that high-yield savings account is just
a gateway drug to get you into their
debt products so stay away from those
and they can be especially tempting too
because a lot of them have slightly
higher rates simply to draw you in like
George said they want you to be in their
system so therefore you're more likely
to get into debt so that's such a good
call out George because we personally
just moved our housing fund into a high
yield savings account and
um it was really tempting we had that
conversation off air where it was like
well is it ethically wrong to go with a
major credit card company that has a
savings account
um and it's just important to think
through that absolutely what kind of
marketing are you going to get from that
but yeah thanks so much for the call
Jamie wishing you the best with the car
payoff it's exciting you're so close 3
000 bucks left then the emergency fund
then you got Financial Peace because you
don't owe anyone anything you've got a
pile of money in the bank and you sleep
better at night and it turns out you're
less concerned about what's happening in
the white house because your house is
okay and that's all that matters at the
end of the day absolutely you can't
control Congress
God bless as we have seen in the last
year but it's a good reminder Christina
for those I'm getting a lot of questions
about high-yield savings accounts lately
because a lot of people they're
comfortable with their Bank they've got
their savings it's making pretty much
nothing and right now interest rates on
savings accounts have skyrocketed and so
I think I'm getting like 3.8 right now
there's some bonuses and things like
that you can get so you can get upwards
of three four percent right now so it's
it may be time to move that money into a
new online high-yield savings account so
that you can you know you want it to
grow a little bit never hurts yeah it's
it's always exciting now we have our
money in that high yield savings account
and we've been getting emails every few
weeks saying hey it's gone up half a
percent that's a nice feeling that's
nice and you can store most of your
emergency phone there I like to keep a
little bit in my checking account as
above first you have immediate access to
it instead of having to wait you know a
day but it's a great option to see your
money grow we love that it's a good word
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Christina Ellis joined Today by George
Hamill we're taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well I know a lot of people out there
are enjoying the beginning of the year
it's such a great time of year to kind
of start fresh there's something really
great about New Year's resolutions I
know they're getting a lot of hate right
now on social media but I personally
love them I love this time to reflect
and think through you know what was good
last year what was bad last year and
what can I improve on this year so this
month I'm super excited my family and I
we are doing a no spend January I love
how fun you make this sound because most
people listening are waiting for
something actual exciting to be said and
you're like we're not gonna spend money
it's so exciting
okay so what's the the heart behind this
well the heart behind it is really just
rebuilding our habits so I I've been
saying that I kind of feel like our
budget has been getting fluffy like my
body has from all the Christmas cookies
so many cookies so we're in baby steps
four through six and it's so easy to
kind of get complacent in this state you
know it's easy to kind of go okay we are
saving a lot to pay off the house but
you know groceries are going up so I'm
going to take a little bit from this
line item you know from our savings and
just up the budget and it's like before
you know it you're looking at your
budget going how are we spending so much
money like it just kind of creeped up so
this is the time where we want to go
okay wait we want to go back to when we
didn't have money when we were really
really fiercely aggressive about things
and we want to just cut back we want to
cut out all non-essentials so that's
really the goal is to cut out all
discretionary spending anything that's
extra so money will still be spent you
still have to pay your bills we're not
saying don't pay your bills everyone
you'll be fine no you got to pay the
essentials keep your four walls together
food utilities shelter Transportation
but beyond your normal bills there's a
lot of luxuries in the budget oh and a
lot of things you can cut back on oh
yeah especially eating out y'all that
last caller was saying that she
struggled with eating out and I was like
I feel you girl that has been such a
thing for us we have two small children
um a one and a four-year-old so we've
kind of been in the thick of things and
it's just easy to be like hey Uber Eats
would you like to deliver something and
also Amazon it's starting to become so
easy to just click without even thinking
and that's been really eye-opening for
me so it's January 4th we've been on day
four of this Challenge and it's really
interesting because I'm already catching
these habits that are kind of
subconscious like oh I need this I'll
just add it to my Amazon cart and so
it's good to just be mindful about your
spending and to just really take that
month or you know even if it's not a
month a week I've had some people on
social media say that they're just gonna
do three days and it's like what ever it
is that challenges you to kind of
rethink how you're spending rethink your
habits and really get focused and locked
in for this year I love it and one thing
that I've seen that works really well
for any habit you're trying to create
including a no spend month is to have a
calendar you can print one out for free
for January do whatever you got to do
and you just write a big X through the
day where you accomplished it where we
went we didn't spend any money we didn't
have to that's a win and then you don't
want to break the chain that's what
happens as you start Crossing out the
days and on the flip side of that then
you still feel like you're winning even
if you have one day that's off so I had
somebody on social media last night say
you know that they struggled one day and
they felt really discouraged but I was
like create that calendar because then
you can see that you know you have 31
days in the month even if you screw up
one day keep going this challenge is
still worth it so I want to challenge
the listeners if anybody out there is
you know starting this year and you're
feeling like hey I really want to get
aggressive with my finances this year
maybe you're in baby step two and you've
had that I've had it moment and you're
like hey I need to figure out how to
press in and get rid of the stat or
maybe you're like us you're in baby
steps four through six and you want to
pay off that house and you're you know
you're feeling the Press of inflation
you're feeling your budget get a little
bit squishy a little bit fluffy and
you're like hey I want to get serious
about this now is the time to do it join
me join us I'll keep you posted on my
progress yeah what are your parameters
for this Christina can you give us a
little Insider details well no eating
out no fun money and we are going for a
100 a week grocery budget wow what is
this 1950 Christina how are you
affording this people are going how do
you spend 100 bucks in feet I mean you
got a big family yeah so I have a meal
plan planned out I have all seven days
kind of mapped out I've mapped out how
much each meal will cost I'm actually
about to share that tonight a social
post I can't wait because I got reamed
for my social media posts saying that
it's cheaper to eat at at home than
eating out and the average cost was
about four bucks a meal at home 13 bucks
eating out and people are freaking out
in the comments going what did he film
did he film this in the 1990s you can't
do that in today's America so I can't
wait to see how much your meals are
costing you yeah you got a family of
four I was talking about per serving not
necessarily four bucks to feed a family
of five in one meal right well and part
of the challenge too is using up your
pantry items so we're gonna be going we
don't have a huge Pantry
um but we do want to use up those items
that sometimes go bad so that's part of
it and then just being really strategic
to figure out what meals can we make
with what we have so so far this week I
spent 45 dollars at the grocery store
wow where are you shopping what grocery
store Kroger for us okay but I'm that
nerd that's going around like with my
calculator like writing everything out
and measuring everything out so that it
like actually fits within it but again
that's a good discipline because I think
we've gotten a bad habit of just kind of
you know getting what we need and and
kind of being a little bit lazy about it
so it's forcing and challenging me to go
back and go no I really need to go to
the store with a meal plan with a list
and stick to my list so I can stay
within those parameters that's big and
when you've got a spouse and they agree
to this it's easy because you have an
accountability partner who is happy to
call you out at every corner but if
you're single you gotta find a friend
who wants to be on this journey too and
they're out there friends I mean you can
find them you can find find them on
social media they're all over our page
join the Ramsay baby steps community on
our on Facebook oh my goodness there's
hundreds of thousands of people in there
who are ready to cheer you on heck yeah
and you can come to my page I am
Christina Ellis on Instagram we've got a
whole community of people who are doing
the challenge together and it's been
really fun even for me just to see
people chiming in I asked how everybody
was doing last night and you know just
to feel those raw emotions with other
people some people are like yeah raw I'm
winning and other people are like this
hurts and it's hard but I love it and
that's kind of where that excitement
comes from is that I'm not doing it
alone and I feel that enthusiasm from
other people so it's a challenge I love
this I already had to pack my lunch
today George oh my goodness I know
that's incredible I know what'd you pack
um I kind of just did a mishmash of
leftovers this would make all the people
who like their food separated kind of
grossed out but it was like all of our
leftovers there were people I found out
who are anti-leftovers they just will
not eat leftovers whoa I'm like what
kind of privileged existence do you have
when you can just say no and throw away
the rest of the food if I did that in my
household Mama camel would not be having
it I'll tell you that much we ate
leftovers for days and it was gross oh
leftovers are my favorite so me and my
wife did this Christina yeah we are
celebrating almost a one year
anniversary of our debt-free scream we
did on that stage uh just about a year
ago I remember that that was such a
great moment and she had the idea of
doing the no spend month and I text her
because I was like I don't remember what
we even did the specifics of it so she
said she shopped our closet so instead
of shopping for clothes oh yeah I forgot
I bought that that shirt still has the
tags on it maybe you should try wearing
that so get creative with clothes with
clothing she would even borrow clothes
from Friends uh she made sure she had
all the makeup and beauty products she
needed we would watch movies at home
instead of going out to the movies eat
at home eat we could get a nice little
steak dinner at home instead of spending
you know 10x that eating out that's so
great and another really key thing
before you start is to analyze your
spending before you jump into this so go
back through the last month's budget and
you know see what did you spend that was
non-essential so add up those line items
add up those transactions and then
figure out your total and that's what
you can save during this month and
that's pretty exciting because then you
can set a goal you know perhaps that's
going to be enough that you could knock
out you know your smallest payment and
your debt snowball or maybe that's going
to be an extra payment on your house so
you know use that as motivation to get
excited and kind of create a why you
know this month it's not going to be
easy they're going to be moments where
you're going to really want to spend
money and having that why clear in your
mind where you're like I'm doing this
because this house is going to get paid
off soon or I'm doing this because I am
getting free from debt you know have
that Vision clear in your mind and like
you said earlier it's like if you have a
bad day you know it's okay don't don't
then give it up and say oh you know not
worth it quitting now like use this as a
challenge the real goal is to change
your habits it's to change how you're
relating to money and really pay
attention I mean you mentioned the word
budget most of y'all probably are going
I haven't even really done a budget well
we'll make it really easy every dollar
is a free app that we created you can do
this in under 10 minutes you can track
your spending and you'll want to throw
up at first but stick with us start
doing the budget three months later you
build the Habit you've got your why and
all of a sudden you're accomplishing
your goals heck yeah so exciting y'all
join us I'm stoked to be on this journey
with you guys we'll be right back this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show well
it's January that means you're probably
about to buy a gym membership that
you'll use two times Max that's a
personal attack Christina I have used it
two times though so do you feel seen yes
for most people January is the month of
failed resolutions but you deserve the
change you want to see in your life and
you can make those changes with the
right tools want to crush your financial
personal and career goals we've got you
if living paycheck to paycheck isn't
your jam get the plan that over 10
million people have used to destroy debt
and build actual wealth with Dave
Ramsey's best-selling book Total Money
Makeover while you're there check out
great tools to help you connect with
people not with Mark Zuckerberg's help
real actual humans with the new
questions for humans decks from Dr John
deloney you're wired to have meaningful
and fun relationships not to stay glued
to your phone it's new year so try to
focus on real relationships with real
people these simple cards take all the
awkward out of conversations they help
you laugh together learn something new
and deepen your relationships and if
you've been quiet quitting your nine to
five job get inspired for a career
change with Ken Coleman's get clear
career assessment you'll learn what you
were created to do and find potential
careers that align with your talents
passion and Mission you can have the
year you want kickoff 2023 with goals
you'll actually stick to shop the tools
to get where you want to go at
ramseysolutions.com door today that's
ramseysolutions.com store and we're here
for you America we're taking your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five let's go to the phones next up
we have Mike calling from Boulder
Colorado
hey Mike welcome to the show
how y'all doing Happy New Year happy New
Year thanks for calling how can we help
um well I my I just got married my wife
and I just found your uh your guys's um
system through our church and um just
wanting to call to see if we're making
the right choice we're purchasing a new
house or we're having a house built I
should say
congratulations on your a lot of
excitement like this is big big Life
Changes
yes
um so where we're where we're at right
now is
um
I have a house and she has a house uh
we're selling both and going to have a
house built
um
I have a lot of equity in my house and
uh own it
um she has her house but she has about
100 100 to maybe 120
000 in equity depending what we can sell
it for and we already purchased we
already went under contract to have a
house built um and that total cost of
that is 800 000.
um
yeah that's a nice house for a newlywed
couple how much Equity do you have in
your house
um well I just put my house on the
market yesterday and it's we're listing
it for about uh
650. okay and you said it's not paid off
so what's left on your mortgage it is
paid off okay you just said you had a
lot of equity I didn't know if it was
paid off or not okay so you would get
that minus fees
right and then and then we have her
house to sell
um and then we would be taking her
equity and my My Equity and all of our
money putting it towards the new house
so we're gonna have to carry a home loan
um and it's
we're thinking it's roughly going to be
anywhere from 80 to about a hundred
thousand and we're I'm just one like I
said we just found your your guys
through our church so I'm just kind of
wondering if we're making the right
choice
well I love that you even have that
question and I'm curious you just found
us through your church but yet you've
seemed to have an aversion to debt
already where did that come from how did
you how did you decide to pay off your
house and learn that
oh my my granddad he's not not I don't
know I just come from I come from a
family that were you know manual
laborers Carpenters coal miners and just
people that just kind of were Frugal
with money so common sense hard workers
yeah I just kind of always
um you know my dad always just taught me
you get paid you fill up your truck you
pay yourself a little bit and then you
put the rest of it so I that's kind of
what I've been doing so that's awesome
it's what we believe you know God and
Grandma's way of handling money so
that's just great that your family
instilled that in you early on and I
love that you're asking this question I
think a lot of people would be going ah
it's just 80 to 100 000 but the fact
that you are like I want it gone yeah
that's a that's a small mortgage for
most of America so way to go on that
front do you guys have any other debt
um she she does have a car and I believe
her her loan on her car is uh I want to
say 16 000. okay and that's it so yeah
pretty relatively small
um well I mean just looking at our
finances and uh we sat down before we
even went under contract with our
Builder to build the new house we think
that we would be fine just figuring what
we make and and um
kind of having a five-year plan and
would hope we could hopefully have this
house the new house paid off
within five years if not sooner have you
guys combined finances yet
uh yeah currently getting ready to do
that yes sir okay that would be step one
is combined finances what will your
household income be or what is it
um I make roughly anywhere from 125 to
130 and she is around
75 to a little over 80 depends we both
work extra work X part-time overtime and
I have a little side business as well so
way to go well here's my thing Mike you
guys could clear this Mortgage in way
less than five years you could do it in
under two
yeah with that yeah especially with the
habits you already have
you've done this before
I think I think we're I think I think we
made the right decision I'm just we're
just I guess we're we're kind of you
know one of those people that or you
never know what's going to happen so
that's why we're like well if it would
be with us no no equity in 800 000 I'd
be like no sir we're not doing that but
um that's why well when's the house
going to be done
a house will not be built until
we won't get the keys and probably until
this July okay so you've got seven
months my goal would also be to keep
saving so pay off this car loan so
combined finances pay off the car loan
then we're saving up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses beyond that the rest of this
money can go towards this new house and
you're going to continue to save over
the next seven months right
oh yes sir so the goal would be how much
can we save and a cool stretch goal
would be to be able to pay cash for this
property when the time comes
even after the debts paid off and we
have the emergency fund yeah yeah that
would be a cool stretch goal if you
don't get there and you need to take out
a really small Mortgage and pay it off
quickly you're going to live but you
guys are just so driven and doing so
well that would just be my goal for you
if I was sitting down kneecap to kneecap
coaching with you
okay and Mike do we stop do we stop any
retirement I mean I've been putting I've
been putting
anywhere from I mean I think I've been
putting 15 if not more under into
retirement can I do I need to stop that
or bump that back down to what you guys
recommend a 15. do you guys have enough
cash right now to pay off the loan
um the car loan
oh um how much money do you guys have in
the bank liquid well I don't know how
much I mean I think she has around
8 000 in the bank I think I have
roughly 15
000 in the bank and I I pay off that car
tomorrow
that's my just my emergency fund well if
you're following the baby steps you said
you're new to the program The Way We Lay
It Out is baby step one thousand dollars
you've got that baby step two pay off
all Consumer Debt from smallest to
largest you're gonna be able to do that
tomorrow then baby step three is save up
three to six months so we would tell you
to clear all cash except for a thousand
dollars for baby step one everything
else goes towards that debt because
think about this you just freed up the
car payment you guys still have money
left over you have an amazing income
that emergency fund is going to be there
in no time and so I would pause
investing in save for that house unless
this week we can clear all that and have
the emergency fund so you may need to
pause temporarily to help create that
margin and Mike stay on the line
Austin's gonna pick up the phone and
we'll put you in Financial Peace
University I know you're new to the
program you have such great money
principles but this will just help you
have some clarity on the specific steps
and action items to take a little gift
for the newlyweds I like that Christina
how nice of you so thoughtful we'll be
right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by my
co-host George Campbell give us a call
at
888-825-5225 next up we have Andrew
calling from Atlanta Georgia hey Andrew
welcome to the show
hey how are you hey we're doing great
thanks for calling how can we help
yeah my question was so I've been out of
college for about six months now and
ever since I've been working my for in
my first career and now that I have a
lot more money than I did coming in
every month in college I'm just not sure
how to utilize it in the best way
because it's a big step up for my
part-time College job
I love it what was your degree in and
what's your job
yeah so I'm in Tech sales here in
Atlanta and my degree was in marketing
and sales that sounds about right way to
go man what what's your income
yeah so depending on commission I would
say uh for before tax and all of that
between 68 and 72. that's a fantastic
start way to go dude yeah that's a great
super proud of you all right so you
haven't had this kind of money to manage
but you obviously have some real life
expenses have you been managing those
all right what's the kind of main pain
points you're feeling
uh going good so far I was able to
thankfully graduate
um without any debt so don't have
anything to Major the payoff like that
the biggest thing is I'm looking to
actually get married in the next year
and a half and just trying to best
prepare myself now financially so I can
walk into that feeling comfortable
financially way to go well the key is
having no debt and having a big pile of
money and that's that's the key for you
and so do you have a reliable car do you
need to upgrade anything in that space
yeah I think I mean my car is probably
like from around 2010 and every once in
a while you'll take an information once
a year but I feel pretty comfortable
with it well you could create a sinking
fund in your budget which just means
we're putting a little bit of money
aside every month because we know the
car isn't going to last another 10 years
potentially right right it could what
kind of car is it
it's a Honda oh it'll go another 10
years just fine that's what's up yeah
and that's one thing to think about and
Andrew you have no other debt correct so
no student loans nothing else
exactly yeah so thankfully I've been
able to be debt free coming out of
college that's wonderful do you have
anything saved right now
yeah right now I'm I haven't been sure
what to do with all the money so I've
just been kind of putting it into all
One bank account it's great that's a
great problem a savings account
yeah it's just a typical savings account
okay and how much do you have in that
account
around 17 000 and then I have uh some
investments in the stock market from
high school and while I was in college
okay are those in single stocks you know
what they're invested in
yeah they were actually gifted to me in
a few different single stocks cool well
one thing I I would do is cash out those
when you're ready because there is going
to be some tax implications based on the
growth of that account so I would work
with it with a tax Pro if you're not
already and also start investing in your
work retirement plan do you have one
over there
is that the same thing as a 401k yes
you've got a 401k through work
yeah I do and I've been uh contributing
everything that they all match so far so
up to the match how much is that
I think it's six percent all right and
is there a Roth option with the 401K or
just traditional
not that I know of I'm fairly certain
that it's just that traditional 401K
okay well you're in the space so if when
you walk through the baby steps you're
out of debt you've got the fully funded
emergency fund with that 17K so you're
on to four which is investing you don't
have kids I assume right no not yet so
that's baby step five is saving for
college then baby step six is paying off
the house early so I imagine you'll be a
homeowner in the next few years at this
rate once you're married yeah it's
definitely something that I want to
consider um and I have one more year
with the roommates now so I've also been
considering getting a house maybe in the
spring and then renting it out but I'm
not sure because that's just a really
big commitment are you talking about
this spring or or next spring
I was potentially thinking about doing
it sometime in the spring early summer
and then letting me and my roommate and
like renting it out to my roommates to
build up some equity in the house to
take into marriage and you would live
there as well correct
exactly so I would live there but I
would also rent the extra available
rooms to roommates but I'm not sure if I
want to have to put all of my eggs in
that basket yeah and that's a huge
Factor too is if you're thinking about
that home purchase I mean spring is
coming up quick a down payment is going
to be key there so I mean 17 000 is
great about how much money are you
thinking about spending on a house
yeah so you know being in the realm of
where I want to with a commute I'm
looking to be in the price range of
about 270 in for a house
um so I just want to I'm willing to
spend whatever but I definitely want to
be able to retain a little nest egg in
case of emergency I'd I'd be really
worried to put all of go all in on a
down payment
sure well some great parameters for you
as you begin this process to make sure
that you're not doing something you know
beyond your emotional boundaries and
financial boundaries is to get it on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay so that really helps
you dictate how much down payment do I
need ideally you can put down 20 or more
which helps you avoid private mortgage
insurance which is just extra money you
throw away to the lender to protect them
in case you can't pay so that's what the
20 threshold will help you do and do
that on a 15-year fixed we have a great
mortgage calculator at
ramseysolutions.com you can use to
figure out those numbers
but that's going to help you walk into
this with a lot of wisdom and a lot of
patience and there's no rush to be a
homeowner tomorrow you're doing great
you're going to get there in no time
because you don't have debt you've got
to pile of money in the bank I would
increase your investing to 15 of your
household income now if you want to save
up that down payment quickly you can
kind of hold off on increasing the
investment that's a Choose Your Own
Adventure there in the baby steps call
it baby step 3B 3B and some people like
to bring their investing down some like
to do 15 while saving that down payment
uh but if you're a gung-ho on getting
this house you might need to pause the
investing for a short period of time
would you say pause it all together and
your shoes when you're not in a rush to
buy a house I would personally just wait
until you're married to make that
decision because guess what your new
spouse is gonna go I don't like this
place I would have chose different
cabinets and so I get that you want to
rent you want to build some Equity
you're going to have your whole the rest
of your life to do that and so I
wouldn't just be in a rush to do it
there's nothing wrong with doing it the
right way like I mentioned with those
parameters but if I'm in your shoes
you're young you got time on your side
you got a great income I would ramp up
your investing of 15 you can max out a
Roth IRA outside of your employer then
you can get that match of course and
increase your investing there well and
Dave often says to wait a year once
you're married to buy a house so you can
know how close you want to live to your
in-laws oh yeah
there are a lot of factors that play in
it though I'm just so proud of this guy
Andrew way to go man yeah you have such
maturity for a guy in his 20s yeah we
talked to people 30 years your senior
who are not talking like this I love it
hey stay on the line we're gonna get you
a copy of baby step millionaires because
I absolutely foresee that this is in
your future the fact that you are this
young and you're already making your
plan this is how it happens you know
just getting intentional getting
aggressive and having a plan this is how
you see these millionaires we're getting
callers on the millionaire theme hour
that are in their 30s they're like early
30s and our debt free screams on the
stage we're going you paid off your
house you guys are 29 and you have a
paid for a house yeah it's amazing and I
think Andrew is going to be one of those
people on that stage just a few years
from now absolutely with his new spouse
going we did it we did it screaming out
there debt free and I think that's just
That's so exciting to me I know you care
a lot about gen Z I get super stoked
about gen Z and Millennials because you
know so often you know they're not
thinking I feel feel like our generation
gets a bad rap you know that we're not
responsible we're not this or that and
it's like we see these people coming in
here who are so aggressive and they're
out there doing it and it's exciting you
know I want to catch these kids while
they're young because it's like this is
how they can build wealth early this is
how they can have Financial Freedom all
throughout their 30s and 40s and 50s and
the rest of their life that's just so
exciting well they get a bad rap because
most of the perception about these
Generations is from social media and the
good ones they're not hanging out on
Tick Tock all day they're busting their
butt working three jobs to pay off debt
to get the down payment they're working
and so they're out there and we get to
meet them and talk to them every day and
it is so encouraging to know that
there's a lot of Hope for the future and
there's so much cynicism Christina in
the news and just the world feels heavy
and the economy and inflation and it
feels like nothing's ever going to get
better and yet I talk to these people
and I go oh it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay our generation's gonna be
okay we can have hope we can have
excitement there's still so much good
out there well that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books thanks to
everyone in the booth thanks to you
America for listening we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality joined today by my co-host
George Hamel also a Ramsay personality
and host of like a million podcast so
much I just love a good podcast what can
I say hey you're great at it we're
taking your calls today give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to the phones first up we
have Carol calling from Lafayette
Louisiana
hey Carol welcome to the show
hi y'all thank y'all for having me hey
thanks for calling how can we help yeah
yes so I became a widow three weeks ago
and so sorry and thank y'all and so
um out of the blue a lady came over and
offered to buy my house four days
afterwards
before my husband died
um he said honey I know it's not going
to be practical for you to stay in this
Home Alone
um we were in the home for 36 years we
found two boys there
and before then we talked about
downsizing and it was all me because I
didn't want to have to you know clean it
but but um you know we um did not and so
I just know I can't do it on my own I
can't stay there on my own because it's
just too too much too much to do by
myself
so what is your advice yeah well Carol
we're so sorry for your loss that's
that's a lot to process especially when
you get into the details and the
finances I'm so sorry what was his name
thank you Ronald what happened to Ronald
he had a geosophical Cancer
and he was diagnosed in July and for
December 6 he was gone oh my goodness oh
I'm so sorry
thank you well how have you been doing
this last few weeks do you have support
around you friends family at church
yes all of the above uh I did right now
I'm at my son's house for a while he
lives out of um 29 Palms California and
I've been you know staying busy they've
been so supportive
I have my grandbaby she's only two and
she's keeping me busy oh that's sweet
they will do that yeah are you okay
financially yeah what does that sound
like I am yes we're debt-free
um no we're not don't have any bills we
are totally debt free no no mortgage or
nothing
no mortgage and nothing no that's great
news well thank God he did a good job of
setting you up as hard as this is it's
great that you're in a strong financial
position
yes yes thank you yes he did he took
care of his business there so tell us
more about this lady so she shows up at
your house and what did you say she
offered you
she wanted to buy my house she straight
up just like knocked on the door
my son was out the one that I'm living
with now for temporary he was out taking
out the trash
and she walked up to him and she says my
husband walked with your dad and I'm so
sorry for your loss but she says I'm
interested in buying your house
y'all's house
and my son came and told me about it and
she called me she wanted to set up a
meeting and she came and
I walked through and she's like this is
all what I wanted I'm ready to buy and
as a matter of fact last night she
texted me again just to keep in touch
and to let me know she was still very
interested is this house for her as a
primary residence is it investment
property what is she planning on doing
with it
oh she wanted for her she wants her
daughter lives like two miles down the
street and she has seven grandkids and
she wanted for her and her daughter
okay have you started working with a
real estate agent yet
I have not I have not and my son is in
the real estate he's also uh fixing to
graduate as an RN and she says oh we
really don't have to go through any of
that she says uh save your money with
all of that because she says you're
gonna have to give them a percentage she
says we can go through you son and just
do it ourselves now you said Your son's
in real estate is he is he like licensed
he is definitely licensed but he's also
yeah he's also about to finish school as
an Orient as well
I just there's something fishy about
this Carol and I can't sniff it out
quite yet but I'm getting some just red
flags about how this whole situation is
percolated do you feel that too yeah
um it was like yeah I was kind of like
where does this come from is this a God
thing because I'm very strongly in the
word of God and I've been a Christian
for
gosh 25 years
um my church is the one who told me
about Dave Ramsey and I've been through
a session with him via you know
um video and so yeah I'm like you
um
that's why I'm calling I I need some
advice how does your son feel about this
does he have that kind of weird weird
feeling in his gut or is he feeling like
good
he's feeling good he says mom maybe it's
a God thing because she said dad get
shaved before he left that he said honey
I know that this is not practical for
you to spend this big Home Alone
and he says you know whatever you decide
he says I understand do you want to move
out do you want to downsize
I do I really do as a matter of fact
with all the support I'm getting from my
two sons I would rather be by them
um I don't have a strong family support
back home uh never did it was just a
weird
family thing that happened to us a while
back and none of us are close anymore
and I've forgiven them all I really have
but I don't have any reason to stay back
home in Louisiana okay I'll be honest
has has she thrown a number out of what
she's willing to offer you and is this a
cash deal
no absolutely not she didn't the only
thing she said related to that was I'm
about to sell my house I'm in now but
she didn't talk price and I didn't talk
price okay I mean right right now my
brother-in-law also is in the housing
business and he said you could easily
get at least over 200 000 for your home
I think what's kind of tricky is and I
think this is what we're all kind of
feeling is there is the risk of a real
estate scam like that's a thing there
are plenty of people out there trying to
prey on people but on the flip side of
that we've also left this crazy housing
market where people have put letters on
people's you know doorsteps they've
knocked on doors because they've had to
be more aggressive so it could really go
either way she could be completely legit
or this could be a classic scam I think
if I'm in your shoes I'm asking a ton of
questions I'm going to verify that her
you know her husband did in fact work
with my husband I'm going to be sitting
down with a real estate attorney I mean
I know your son has experience but I
want to sit with somebody who has legal
experience I want to have their support
and advocating for me and really asking
those deep hard questions yeah this is
the biggest financial decision you've
probably ever made and so this is not
something where we do a handshake deal
and just hope so absolutely I'm gonna go
to ramsaysolutions.com click on Ramsay
recommends click on real estate get in
touch with a real estate endorsed local
provider those are folks in your area
that our team has vetted that are Ramsay
trusted to make sure that they take care
of you the right way they're not going
to scam you and here's what you really
need to do is work with a pro so that
they can get you top dollar I'm not
worried about the fee this isn't about
money at this point this is making sure
that you're protected financially and
they will get you top dollar and if she
wants to go through them the right way
then I'm doing that deal but only then
so tread with caution absolutely we'll
be right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five give us a
call we want to talk about your life and
your money
today we have our question of the day
coming from Dakota and Florida
she asks would it be possible to use a
student loan to repair my car my car is
paid off I bought it cash but it has
major engine problems and I was told by
the mechanic it would cost nearly three
to four thousand dollars to fix it with
another engine I will need a way to get
to school and eventually work very soon
so will taking out a federal student
loan suffice I do understand that you
can use student loans for vehicle
operation and maintenance since it falls
under the transportation category I just
don't know what to do oh George George
this is a dicey one so technically when
you take a student loan out they're not
monitoring what you do with that student
loan it sounds like she's saying she's
going to take out a new student loan in
order to do this which is one of the
worst types of loans you could take out
because number one high interest rates
and number two you can't even discharge
them right that's really scary well and
what's crazy is this is a really common
thing right now because you can take out
student loans for your cost of living
and I mean that can be kind of squishy
right because what council's cost of
living a vehicle repair a lot of people
end up shopping I mean there's a lot you
can take out student loans for sadly and
we hear all the time from people who did
that and now 10 years later they're
still paying on that loan and they are
stressed out yeah and the student loan
companies they don't care about you
meaning they don't care what you do with
that money because as long as they're
getting that interest they're happy
right so they're not going to sit there
monitoring what you do with it well and
they're paying they're preying on
vulnerable people right like college
students or college students that's a
great example right we were all broken
college at least most of us and so to be
able to have this like you know pot of
money where it's like hey hey do you
need this it's tempting it's really
tempting so I would not do the student
loan we are not going into debt for this
but here's what we can do we can do more
homework I'm getting a second opinion
from another trustworthy mechanic to
actually see is this a three thousand
dollar repair now I don't know how much
money you have in the bank I don't know
you you said you're working very soon is
there things you can sell do you have
family that might be able to help out
can you borrow a car we've got to get
creative but as long as debt is off the
table then we can actually come up with
some different ideas but the solution
here is not let's go take out a student
loan to get back on the road well and
that's the key taking debt off the table
because it's like a lot of times when
you know that there's a way out when you
know that there's an easy way out then
it's like you don't come up with that
creative thinking but if debt is not an
option you're gonna find a way even if
it's hard even if it's not pretty even
if you have to sell something that you
like you're gonna find some creative way
to pay for this and when it comes to car
repair here's a good way to think about
it we get a lot of calls about car
repairs and you got to think about can
you recoup the cost of the repair so if
you have a four thousand dollar car and
the repair is going to cost three
thousand dollars but then the car only
becomes worth five thousand it's not
worth it you may just want to save up
and get a different car altogether and
so we don't know how much you paid for
it we don't know what the value of the
car will be as is if she fix it up and
so there's more homework to do you can
do a lot of research online about the
value of the car KBB repair pal there's
so many resources out there to figure
those pieces of the puzzle out well and
it's
count three to four thousand dollars
that's a scary number when you need a
vehicle to get somewhere and it breaks
down that that's a lot to think through
coming up with quickly but like you said
if you do have to get rid of that card
there are Clunkers out there for a
thousand bucks I mean they may not be
great the AC may be a little bit Shifty
um but they're out there and they can
get you from one place to another so
even if it's it's not a glamorous option
even if it's
um if it's a challenge just remember
it's a season and you can continue to
fight and figure out you know how can
you pay for either the repair or a new
car absolutely that's a tough one broke
college students ugh and student loans
man we remember that life right all
right let's go to the phones next up we
have Frank calling from New York City
hey Frank welcome to the show
all right thank you so much for having
me thanks for calling how can we help
uh I have a question I just have a
question about
um College savings I'm at I followed
Dave Ramsey Solutions and I'm right now
at step five basically where I want to
put money into college savings for my
two kids now my only problem is that I
looked at the past home of performances
of these um of the 529 plan options they
don't look so good
um can you guys provide some sort of
like a alternative solutions to college
savings or if not uh or if you guys you
know really you know more going home on
the 529 can you provide everybody some
sort of like a confidence thing because
I don't see any confidence in the uh in
these options and I'm sure I'm not the
only one yeah well we typically
recommend that you start with an
education savings account because they
do have more flexibility in how you
invest your money so it's similar to a
Roth IRA it's funded with post-tax
dollars and that's just a really great
way to start the challenge with that is
that it's got a two thousand dollar a
year limit and it does have some income
limits so 220 000 if you're married a
hundred and ten thousand dollars if
you're single so if you do qualify
though that's a great place to start
because you do have more flexible
investment options and then from there
we recommend going to the 529 are you
familiar with esas
uh yes I'm familiar with with both Esa
and 529 it's just that like I said like
you know I'm I'm looking at all these
performances are you looking at like the
past year or two performance
yeah yeah the past four months yes well
if that's look at your 401k it's going
to have a very similar sad result it's
been a real down market for a period of
time now uh so I wouldn't let that hold
you back from investing because we look
at this as a long-term play so when are
you going to need this money for college
oh my my son my two kids are
um seven and four right now so probably
in like another 10 to 10 to 13 years you
know give or take
um you know and with that being said a
follow-up question if you don't mind is
how do I put money into like so what I
mean by this is should I put a lump sum
into the esa or to the 5.529 or should I
spread it into monthly installments into
the account
I mean do you have a chunk of money
right right now that you're you're
wanting to invest in one of the options
uh well to be honest I do have a roughly
around uh 10K right now now I was I was
thinking about we're doing half half
each one gets half but like like I'm
trying to see if I should put it into
some like put it all in one shot or
should I spread it I mean I think that's
more of a personal preference I I think
if you do a lump sum it's still good to
have a consistent monthly amount that
you're doing over time because it is
easy and tempting to do that 5000 up
front and then kind of forget about it
and then you get in panic mode in high
school so I think it's really about like
you know your discipline and being able
to consistently invest over time yeah
the lump sum will allow more time for
that lump money to grow uh the other
side is what we call dollar cost
averaging where you're just putting a
consistent amount of money in every
single month and that's also a tried and
true strategy and really what you're
trying to do there we can't time the
market we never recommend that it's all
about time in the market and so either
way is great and Dave Ramsey would say
hey if you get the money go ahead and
just put the lump sum in and forget
about it uh but if that's something
where it's a budget line item for you
you can just invest a portion of that
every single month over 12 months so you
can't go wrong the fact that you're even
asking these questions tells me these
kids are going to go to school debt free
but do not jump off of the roller
coaster right now we're in the middle of
the ride and it's the not fun part of
the ride but give it a year give it two
years give it five years ten years like
you mentioned and you're gonna see that
money grow way more than it would have
in a savings account so that's the key
well and so that's the financial side of
things but with a seven and a four year
old the other thing is to really invest
in their education right now and in
their mindset about college so you know
teaching them about scholarships I know
it seems kind of silly it's early on but
even just starting to talk about college
starting to talk about extracurricular
activities and getting them involved
early on can be helpful I talk to a lot
of parents who you know have Juniors and
seniors in high school and they're like
how do we motivate our kids to do stuff
all they want to do is sit around and
play video games and a lot of times I
ask them I'm like well have they been
involved in activities before now and
they're like like no they they haven't
really had a lot of discipline so it's
hard for them to make that big shift and
pivot to now being like well now we want
them to win scholarships so they need to
build a resume and they need to do all
these things that they haven't been
doing over time oh absolutely but it's
like get your kids active early on start
volunteering as a family and get them
thinking about you know the future it
doesn't need to be some crazy high
pressure over-the-top extra thing but
just get their mindset you know thinking
about their future early on in a way
that's fun and and gets them just
excited and if this is something that it
gives you some worry at night get in
touch with one of our smartvestor pros
at ramsaysolutions.com they can walk you
through all of the options with esa's
529s and give you some hope and
confidence in that future we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined Today by George
camel we're taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
next up we have Nancy calling from
Indianapolis Indiana hey Nancy welcome
to the show
hi thank you both and I just
accomplished um
the will of God to get through today
I've had those burdens and I just needed
counseling and your wisdom so thank you
for taking my call thanks for calling a
shout out to your screener you're
welcome because he helped me try to sum
up my dilemma oh Austin's the best in
the game that's very kind absolutely
thank you okay basically my my youngest
niece is in college over in Australia
and she's about to enroll in her third
year this month or yes so
um her mom is really not involved in her
life
and so I felt burdened because at least
my niece and I have a relationship so I
feel burdened for her outcome for her
success so I've been helping her these
past couple years with her tuition and
living expenses although she has been
working the Lord's provided for her but
at this point with her third year she
doesn't see her schedule work really
working out for work so because her
mom's not really involved
but I guess part of my frustration is
Mom and I or her mom and I had received
an inheritance and she was given more
because she at the time she had three
dependents and this was in the last
six seven years
um
so I don't like it that I'm even feeling
mercenary I don't like that and I feel
like this is like a shining light on me
not trusting the Lord to provide for me
I'm looking at my inheritance so because
of this burden I feel to help my knee
succeed and I and I believe in her
because she had right now she has this
Vision this goal that's why she went
into University
and but because it's
in a way straining my wealth in a sense
I want her mom to step in what's going
on with her mom have conversation with
her mom well
I guess bottom line
um she's in I to me it's a cult and I
felt for your previous caller I guess
two calls ago this is a device she was
saying it's just something weird to
happen her family well this is weird too
so the leaders has everybody turn their
backs and anybody who doesn't support
him
so I feel the Lord we're talking like a
religious cult like a Scientology level
situation
yeah well it's it's I think it's small
base
and it just has been devastating
um my niece and I so I feel because she
was living overseas my niece went over
to Hillsong and it because of Hillsong
and then left and because her goals
change and it's just as well because
that church has had its own share of
problems so what is she doing now
okay
um her goal is she went the children
went through foster care
he and her sisters so her heart is my
niece's heart has always been her
children
and she wants to be in like a social
care system that foster care
um which I commend her for and she's
still in Australia
yes why isn't she back stateside family
there's no reason for her to come back
she doesn't I'm not enough to bring her
back you know it's like the whole family
has just divided themselves I imagine
College though is more expensive in
Australia for her than it would be here
well she's able I guess her expenses are
minimal because she's not able to do
anything you're floating her expenses
that's what I wondered okay I had that
thought so here's here's my honest take
on this Nancy
she needs to move back to the states she
needs to go to an in-state School
Community College because tomorrow her
goals might change again and Aunt Nancy
is floating all the expenses at the
detriment of her own financial situation
and she's just riding High riding free
and I understand you want to help her
but it feels like she's taking advantage
of you in a way
yeah okay do you feel that go ahead do
you feel that at all yes I don't think
it's malicious but I don't want you to
feel this burden emotionally that you
now have to be her mother and you need
to take care of her every expense she
can work I worked in college with a full
schedule graduated a half semester early
Christina worked it's possible and uh
I'm not saying she's out there partying
every day but as a student you have time
in between classes and in between
studying to work
and so I'm going to challenge that piece
of it and I'm also going to challenge
the fact that she needs to go Eat Pray
Love in Europe to get this degree to
take care of kids
do you agree am I more angry about this
than you are just I'm just hearing this
facts on paper for the first time I
kind of sunset I maybe I was just
hesitant to bring that up I felt either
you need to do this this and this or
you're coming home you're coming back I
just think you're a really sweet person
and I'm worried that you're becoming a
doormat for her to say well my life's
been hard mom's out in the picture Aunt
Nancy got this inheritance she's okay
and at the same time I don't want you to
have to delay your own retirement and
have no wealth and be in a really sucky
financial situation because you allowed
yourself to feel like a burden for this
girl okay okay just Free Yourself of
that
have you had any conversations with your
niece about this
oh well yes but not but not at the I
don't know not to the point where no you
need to consider coming home because I
can't be funding you I haven't had that
conversation how much are you giving her
per month
well if this I don't know if I can
average I did look at for years how much
have you given her the last few years
I'd say
maybe close to not I don't know if it's
even 20 000. I know the two-year tuition
in U.S money has been 32 to 34 000 per
year or over two years no for two years
I if you want to continue giving but
have boundaries around it you could say
Hey listen you're in your third year I'm
going to continue giving you let's say
500 a month for those two years the rest
is on you you need to work you need to
figure it out but this is as much as I
can do right now financially
okay and that's very generous on your
end and if you want to say hey I can no
longer do this starting tomorrow she's
gonna have to figure it out and she's
young and she's resilient uh and she
she's living on her own right in
Australia
yes yes and hey Nancy this may be a
non-point but
um does the mom still have inheritance
or did that go to the cult
yeah that thank you that's that's what
it's been I I know a big chunk of it is
gone to this cult do you know if there's
um with her getting more inheritance um
because of the three dependents do you
know if any of that money was in the
kids names or was it all in in your
sister's name I think it was in my
sister's name yeah and no other family
involved in this situation
no it's just she and her two of her
daughters and even a granddaughter
okay so you feel like that money is gone
there's probably no way to get that to
actually go towards pretty much because
my yes because my niece has hinted his
or felt as much that she didn't think
her mom really is in the position to
give and maybe
that's why her she has her mom has an
offered to help her
gosh what a sad situation yeah well I
love your heart Nancy I really do I I
want the best for both of you and I
don't think that means you have to just
Fork over all of your money to fund her
life for an indescript amount of time I
don't think that's the best for either
of you
yeah Nancy you are so sweet
oh it's gonna take a hard conversation
with her and really get the details of
hey what is your plan here's how much
you need to also sit down and figure out
how much am I willing to give if any
more but not just an open bank account
for her to take from either
yeah and your heart is your heart is in
the right place and I think that there's
a lot of you know grief at the loss of
you know the relationship with your
sister there's grief that your niece was
in the foster care system there's a lot
of emotions tied into this but it's
important to kind of separate you know
what can you do from a mentor
perspective what can you do to love your
niece well versus what needs to happen
financially because you're not
responsible for what happened with their
mother and her finances that's that is
your sister's bad decisions and you
don't have to make up for it but I do
love your heart and your care for her
Nancy that that's you're a very sweet
woman but be willing to have that hard
conversation we'll be right back this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show about
this time of year we get flooded with
calls because everyone's looking for a
fresh start with their money especially
after a couple tough years so if that's
you you can't wish for things to change
and expect it to happen you've got to do
some different things with your money
and have a plan and we can teach you
that plan in Financial Peace University
this is the course that will help you
rethink how you manage your money and
you'll learn step by step how to pay off
debt and build wealth guys nearly 10
million people have taken FPU followed
this plan and changed their lives it
works don't try to reinvent this and
when you intentionally follow this plan
with focused intensity this year it will
be different you will have more peace in
your finances and your life so start
Financial Peace University right now at
ramsesolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com
slash FPU next up we have Carol Carolyn
calling from Green Borough North
Carolina
hey Carolyn welcome to the show
hey thank you for taking my call of
course how can we help
yes so
um my question has to do with
um Brent versus buying but it's a little
bit more nuanced so
um we're basically in a situation where
we're already renting as cheaply as
possible
um we even had to move over to Summer to
avoid a rent hike that put it way
outside of our budget um
and we can't seem to follow the 25 of
take-home rule essentially
um our original plan was to rent
um really cheap for a while and have a
big down payment and buy a family home
but now I'm wondering if it would make
more sense to look to buying something
like a condo or a town home
for something close to anywhere between
like 80 and 90 000 and going ahead and
purchasing that
um since we can't
get that percentage down to 25 percent
what's your income right now and what's
your rent
um right so our rent right now is 8.25
um my my husband's working he's take
home is about
um 2 200 a month
um we're newly married so we've been
married about a year and four months
um I was working part-time and then I
had her son and I stopped working
um my plan is to be a stay-at-home mom
there are a few things I'm planning on
doing on the side that should bring in
maybe close to 400 a month
um which would bring our I guess our
take-home it's close to 26 2600 a month
okay yeah I don't see this as a you know
I know we the percentages are really
helpful but it's not a legalistic uh
piece of the equation what I do think is
the bigger problem here is the income
there's just not enough coming coming in
you know if you're going to be staying
at home we need to get his income up to
where we're still able to live our life
and invest 15 percent and say for
college for this baby and pay off the
house early and if we can't do that we
need more margin and there's only two
ways to get it make more or spend less
and it sounds like you guys are doing
your very best on the spend less side
yes yeah so we're at the biggest thing
I'm trying to tweak right now is just
groceries
um his job is I mean he's only been
working professionally for two years
um I'm 24 and he's 23.
um and we expect well he's been promised
basically a promotion and a rate he's
already had one he hasn't been at the
job yet for even a year
um so we expect growth on that end
um what does he do
I'm sorry what does he do for a living
he's a project manager
um so he's he's working for a relatively
new company so they basically hired a
whole bunch of young people and put them
in complicated positions so it's been
good for him he's been able to get a lot
of experience really fast
um the salary isn't there necessarily
yet
um I mean he has a salary but it's not
doesn't really match what he's doing but
the company is growing really fast so
we're hopeful that
he will be able to progress quickly he's
been told that he'll get promoted to a
senior project management position
um by the second quarter of this year
that's good news and so do you guys have
any debt
no we don't have any debt um we already
have an emergency savings built up
um and we have 30 000 already saved for
a down payment wow on top of the
emergency fund
is that right
yeah if you're a fully funded emergency
fund plus thirty thousand
correct yeah we plan on putting a little
bit more in the emergency fund now that
we have a baby but
um how did you guys get to that amount
um I well we saved we were both
homeschooled kids to conservative
parents and
um we were just raised that way I was
able to get through college debt free
and worked all the way through
um he has an associate's degree he's
planning on going back to get a
bachelor's at some point
um yeah I don't know so everything that
I was making before
um I left my job and had a baby we just
put straight into that down payment
that's awesome that's really awesome so
tell us about the condo is that is that
an option that it's like oh man that's
like last resort we're not excited about
it or could you see yourself living in
that condo for a while and being being
content
well not we're not super excited about
it
um our plan will plan now like in the
apartment we were in we got it's it's
small but there's two bedrooms so the
whole plane I was like technically we
could fit three kids in here I mean we
plan on having a large family so
um that that was the plan but then when
I think about condos I mean just I've
looked for there's not very many on the
market right now but just looked around
a little bit basically you can get a
condo that's roughly the same size of
our apartment
um and it's the same sort of deal like
we could manage to live there probably
five years or so
um longer if necessary but
um what are those condos cost
um it's seems to vary and I'm I'm not as
familiar with the city we're currently
in so part of that I need to look at
like crime maps and stuff
um but roughly they're going for
anywhere between 80 and 90 000. okay
so you guys would have uh if you got the
condo today which you're in a position
to technically do it with 30 000 down on
a 90 000 condo uh that would put you on
a 15-year fix at a payment of about 7 30
or so
right yeah now you do have the extra
cost there may be HOA there's going to
be home maintenance repairs property
taxes home insurance is going to be
higher than renters insurance so you
want to factor all those pieces in but
as far as a financial equation you could
do this
okay and I okay my first home was a town
home and we loved it and you don't have
a lot to worry about with condos and
Townhomes versus single-family homes so
I think it's a great step for you guys
if you really want to get out of the
renting game
okay
um honestly like we're we're renting now
we're
now we're there versus renting so really
we're open to do I just wouldn't be in a
rush for the next five years I mean it
is so wonderful when the toilet breaks
you just call someone and they just show
up and fix it and so there's especially
with a baby uh so there's a lot of great
things about renting there's a it gets a
bad rap but for a lot of situations it's
a good move and long term it's always a
great move to be a homeowner so I would
encourage you to do that but if you want
to save up more and go hey we want a
single family home that's going to be
double the cost we need to wait till we
have a bigger down payment there's a lot
of wisdom in that too when you guys are
good Savers like you guys have saved
quite a bit on on a relatively small
income in the grand scheme of things so
as your husband gets raises and you
continue to be aggressive with your
finances you know in a year or two the
the opportunity to get a single family
home maybe within reach while still
keeping it under that 25 percent you
know do you feel in your gut that you
would rather wait it out or do you kind
of feel that rush to buy something
I definitely don't feel a rush to buy
something
um it's just I mean recently it's just
struck us how frustrating it is to just
throw rent money you know out the window
um when we could be putting it towards
something like a condo
um and then have that to sell in
five-ish years is put towards a single
family home so
yeah I can I can really just see it
going either way so it's it's nuanced
and we haven't just been sure what to do
with that I would just set a goal and
say hey you're from now we want to be in
a position to buy we here's what we're
kind of looking at and just be about
that savings goal yep and I think you're
in a really great position I love that
this is this is something that could go
either way and you'd be comfortable in
that position I mean you're set up with
the down payment if you want to do a
condo I think you wouldn't go wrong but
also since you are in a hurry and you're
content renting you know if you're
willing to wait it out you might be able
to get something that you're a little
bit more excited about in here I think I
think it's a hard one where it's really
going to have to be some soul searching
and what you want to do all right that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books thanks to everyone in the booth
and thanks to everyone listening we'll
be back soon
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality
Christina Ellis joined today by my
co-host George Campbell give us a call
at
888-825-5225
we have Tanner calling from St Louis
Missouri hey Tanner welcome to the show
hi Jordan Christina thanks for taking my
call hey thanks for calling what's up hi
I had a quick two-part question one
question is about how I should start
filling up my Roth IRA for 2023 and the
second part is about a future home
purchase love it how old are you
20 years old amazing crushing it already
all right what's the question
uh I was wondering on my Roth IRA if I
should Max it out now in January or
through the news and I should spread it
out over the course of the Year given
that I have the money now to Max it out
entirely for the year awesome so you're
completely debt free fully funded
emergency fund and you've got this money
to throw into investing yeah uh
debt-free twenty thousand dollar
emergency fund about 39 000 in my
checking account about 48 000 in a
business account oh my goodness are you
an entrepreneur 20 years old this is
like you are so far ahead of the game
how did this happen
uh I started a lawn care business when I
was about 15. just five years ago and
here you are yeah oh my goodness you're
my hero way to go dude that's amazing is
that where that 39 000 came from or the
money in your checking account
yeah the 39 and the personal and then
the 48th in the business but I want to
keep the stuff in the business for now
yeah has that just been something you
saved up over the last year or or kind
of how did that come about uh last
couple last two probably mostly
okay so what what has kind of made you
decide now to want to put it somewhere
versus where it's kind of been building
slowly
uh I did my rust last year of the 6000
for the 2022 tax season and then I just
didn't like might as well start doing
retirement early while I can and get a
jump on everything
yeah we love that so let's talk about
this Roth IRA so what we're talking
about here is a lump sum versus dollar
cost averaging and in all of my research
it's been funny because you kind of get
to the end back to where you started
which is we just don't truly know
because the market is going to do what
the market does so let me explain what
that means if I let's say a dollar cost
average well if the market Falls and
then it rises dollar cost averaging
would take advantage of those lower
prices of those shares during that time
but if I put the money in and then it
rises and Falls lump sum investing would
lock in that lower price at the start of
the year and so there's kind of it just
depends on the market and here's the a
good way to think about it if you're
primarily concerned with minimizing your
risk and potential feelings of regret if
you put
let's say you put 6 000 in and all of a
sudden two weeks from now it's down to
five thousand that just hurts
emotionally as an investor doesn't it
yeah it does that's kind of what
happened last year because my six
thousand's down to 5400 and then I put
five thousand in the regular IRA and
that's down a couple hundred too exactly
let's lose money so that's a perfect
example to describe the feelings now uh
then dollar cost averaging would be a
better course of action for you because
emotionally you can ride that roller
coaster more steadily you're taking
advantage of all the dips and the Rises
and uh so you're kind of averaging that
out and so either way you're going to be
a multi-millionaire and all the research
I found they're going hey really it's
negligible you might be looking at you
know one or two percent difference
depending on how you did it uh now if
you have the money and you're a
long-term investor which you're 20 years
old so you've got a whole lot of time
ahead of you I would just throw it in
there and not think about it and not
worry about it and just do that every
single year but watching the the return
one year later is unhelpful because if
you've looked at your 401k if you're
listening right now in the last year
you're depressed because you're like
I've been putting money in but it's
lower than where I started how is this
possible right
so that's my answer on that one it's a
Choose Your Own Adventure and if you've
got the money to just throw and not
worry about it because you're thinking
long term then just go ahead and do the
lump sum but I'm also assuming that the
rest of that 39 has something to do with
your next question about the house
yeah uh I currently live at home rent
free and my current thought is I have so
much equipment to store so an apartment
or rental doesn't really fit my
situation optimally my current thought
is do I just save up for a sizable down
payment while living at home or what
would you recommend because everything's
pretty good here at home
yeah my goal would be to I mean you're
you've got the entrepreneurial Spirit
you clearly have a great financial
Foundation underneath you I would say
you're ready once you've got that down
payment to get a home and it you know
maybe a doesn't have to be a single
family home it could be a town home have
you looked at home prices in your area
not entirely I need something with like
a large garage or a large large ARC
building so nothing probably under 200.
okay and how much do you have outside of
the emergency phone that you would say I
can use this towards a down payment
uh just the 39 in the personal at the
moment I have about a 30 000 paid for
truck and about 43 000 in equipment but
all that's business and stuck in the
business for now awesome and what is
your income what are you taking from the
business uh
uh let's see that's your Revenue to
about a hundred and forty thousand but
only probably 30 or 40s profit on that
and next year I'll probably Revenue
about one well this year I'll Revenue
both 160 probably but I don't know
exactly what profit will be on that okay
where where is all the revenue going are
you paying a team
equipment oh no it all went into
equipment for this uh the 2022 season
mostly okay so next year though or this
this year you're gonna have a lot less
expenses so you can take more of that
home correct way less exactly so that
would be my goal it's about a truck and
bunch of memories last year great so I
would set a goal for that down payment
do some research on the homes and say
hey I really would love 250 is about the
price point I'm looking at to get the
right home I want to have at least a 20
down payment I want the payment to be no
more than a quarter of my take-home pay
on a 15-year mortgage what does that
look like and then you can set a real
nice hard deadline a hard goal of I want
to save up to 60 000 for that down
payment seven months from now or a year
from now and then start shopping
yeah that would be pretty possible I
just need to make sure I can make it
with tax returns and no having zero
credit score yeah and you can do that
I've done it it's called manual
underwriting it's a no score loan now
the thing you do need to think about
Tanner is they will not accept uh you
know living at home as a true rental
payment so you might need to go rent
somewhere for a year which you can
absolutely afford you might need to
store the equipment you know back home
with your parents for now but you're
going to need a form of of proof that
you actually paid rent payments to a
landlord to a company versus your
parents so you can look into those
parameters on our website Churchill
Mortgage do I use they have a great list
of what they're looking for when it
comes to manual underwriting so I don't
want to steer you wrong here because a
lot of people Christina said well that
you said I could do manual underwriting
but you do need 12 months proof of you
know cell phone bills utility bills rent
all of that matters right they do need
to have some way to prove that you're
reliable they still are loaning you a
significant amount of money so there is
some sort of verification to that so
that's something to think about as you
begin this process but you don't need to
go play the credit score game to do this
you're a bright young man I mean you
this guy could pay cash for a home a few
years from now 20 years old that is just
so that's so outstanding and it's just
also such a a highlight point of you
know even without a four-year college
degree even without following a certain
path you can be super successful and you
can even do that while you're in college
he's doing way better than your son
Junior over there getting his underwater
basket waving degree at 100 Grand a year
you don't need to do this this kid is an
amazing amazing inspiration for so many
out there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined Today by George
camel we are taking your calls on your
life and your money give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right Christina you know I live
on the internet I'm working on my phone
addiction this year it's one of my
resolutions but because of that I get to
see all the great videos on social media
before anyone else and usually they make
me angry and they rile me up but I
stumbled across one that made me laugh
and brought me a little bit of Joy it's
a little bit dark but I think you're
going to enjoy it can we play it let's
do it all right roll that clip
I have thousands of dollars in gambling
debt
that you would all probably call student
loans
[Laughter]
[Music]
but I like to look at that as me betting
on myself
uh brilliant a brilliant comedian just
perfect timing and delivery in such a
beautifully dark analogy about student
loans I couldn't decide whether to laugh
or cringe well you're a better person
than me I immediately laughed that's
just straight up and it's coming from a
comedian so clearly she doesn't take
herself too seriously but the analogy
that's the reality to that think about
this but then I was like oh the student
loan companies are like the Vegas
casinos and they're inviting you in with
open arms oh saying you can win big and
she's saying I'm betting on myself and
the funny thing is The House Always Wins
don't they the student loan companies
always win
just so sad and also also
I'm allowed to laugh at that right yes
gosh Christina live a little live laugh
persevere we all know how the saying
goes It's funny but it's also so true so
it brings me to my next Point there's
this uh article from Yahoo here's the
headline get this meet the 30 year old
with a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in student debt who chose her jobs in
hopes of Public service loan forgiveness
but her balance just keeps growing like
a fungus this uh this woman Kirsten Lane
she's 30 years old and she had
undergraduate graduate degrees went into
a career in the non-profit sector in
theory to get the Forgiveness which in
reality didn't quite work out the
elusive forgiveness and she says I never
miss a payment always on time and yet my
balances never go down I don't
understand how people can't see that
there's something wrong with this
picture and here's the Great crazy part
she obviously I guess found out this
program is riddled with flaws the public
student loan forgiveness program so she
paused that strategy for that 10-year
program to taking marketing agency job
in the private sector with a salary that
brings her much closer to the 90 grand
the federal government estimated she
would need to afford to pay back the
debt goodness gracious well it's
interesting too because she said she
went to her dream School counting on
forgiveness so basically like that
little carrot that was dangled of
forgiveness actually affected which
school she chose and what career she
chose right but she actually went to a
more expensive school because she was
counting on that forgiveness and you're
like who why does it matter they're
going to forgive it no matter the cost
oh until they don't until they don't
well and that's what's kind of obviously
man this gets me fired up but it's like
this is what is so scary about this
conversation about forgiveness and all
of these students who are going to
school who are looking to go to college
is that now going to make them pick more
expensive schools because they think
someday they're going to get their loans
forgiveness or it's going to be capped
there's income based repayment so I
might as well borrow 300 000 because I'm
only going to pay five percent of my
salary if you're out to dinner and a
generous person is like hey guys I'm
covering the dinner get whatever you
want you're not getting the cheapest
thing on the menu right you're going to
get an appetizer you're going to get the
steak maybe some dessert maybe a
cocktail and that's kind of how it is
with these student loans and the
forgiveness program they're just going
I'm going to go to whatever my dream
school is whatever the cost is and the
Monopoly money well that's for someone
else to worry about
and it just doesn't pan out like that in
reality and no one makes the money they
thought they would make Because by the
way to get the Forgiveness you've got to
be in the public sector which by the way
pays less on average than the private
sector and so you get stuck in these
rhythms and she calls it a catch-22 in
the article and she goes on to say I was
paying 300 bucks until the pandemic hit
and I think for three or four years my
balances never went down they always
went up
well and that that alone is a bit
problematic because with a hundred and
ten thousand dollar balance paying 300 a
month with a balance going up that means
you're just paying interest you're not
really tackling the prince it must mean
the interest is high enough and the
payment is low enough that you're not
making any progress on that balance and
I you know when I hosted The Borrowed
future podcast series we did I talked to
Terry who had fifteen thousand dollars
of student loan debt that ballooned up
to 60. decades later
as life hit her and she struggled and
she was suicidal it was so sad talking
to her and hearing her heart going I was
worth more dead than I was alive
that is that is sad and so many people
feel this way when it comes to student
loans they're going I was told that this
was going to be the best thing for me
the guidance counselors the student loan
companies the marketing it's all saying
we're investing in your future and uh
like that comedian said I bet on myself
and I lost that's what it feels like
when it comes to student loans well and
that's that's kind of the way they sell
it too is it's like it's good debt it's
good debt it's how you advance it's
necessary everybody's doing it and it's
not and this it's just not this quote
from her in the article sums it up the
hardest thing is that I trusted in the
system that I was told from a very young
age was going to be my path to
Prosperity or a decent not exorbitant
but a decent middle class life where I
could give back to the community that
helped raise me and supported me and
that that's and she said it feels like a
big broken promise now and that
describes the entire uh college system
student loan system that we find
ourselves in today and we covered this
in depth in the borrowed future
documentary which is now free on YouTube
and Christina you were featured in that
kind of showing the other side of saying
hey you don't have to go down this path
you can go to college debt free it's
possible and as possible I want over
half a million dollars in scholarships
my mom gave me a challenge my freshman
year of high school and basically said
you're on your own paying for college
but at the same time I expect you to go
to college and you know expect you she's
an immigrant from Venezuela and so she
was like I worked to get this far now
you got to take the Baton further so how
are you going to get scholarships how
are you going to go to school debt free
and that really encouraged me to start
hustling you know I did a ton of
volunteer work in high school I did a
ton of extracurricular activities and
then I treated the scholarship
application process like a part-time job
my Junior and Senior year and so it is
possible you know but you got to take
student loan debt off the table we have
to you know get it through to students
that that's not the way when you're when
there's no debt on the table when that
is not an option you're gonna get
creative and find ways and it's so
interesting people have talked to me and
they're like Christina you must have
been anti-debt you know when you're were
in high school but at the time honestly
I didn't even know that like I could get
student loans thankfully thankfully my
mom being from Venezuela was a benefit
for us they handled debt a bit
differently there so I didn't realize
that I could take out student loans I
thought if I didn't have enough cash to
pay for college if I didn't find a way
to pay for it that I couldn't go to
school so that really motivated me to
figure out how to win scholarships and
to get myself out there you know but
taking debt off the table it just really
encourages you to be strategic and to
figure out different ways and you know
something else I'm pretty concerned
about over the next year that I think
people need to be really mindful of is
there's a lot of changes happening right
now with public student loan forgiveness
and this program has already it's misled
a lot of people over the last several
years I think it was like two percent of
people who who applied for the program
actually got their debt forgiveness
um there's there's been some waivers
recently they're saying there's some
full things going into effect in June
it's all still TBD there's a lot kind of
out there so I think it's just important
to encourage students to still go to
school debt free I mean this is all it's
all the Forgiveness stuff right it's it
sounds it sounds so beautiful it sounds
so attractive but then you have stories
like Kirsten's where she's a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in debt still
waiting to see if it's gonna happen and
just getting frustrated so y'all you are
the solution to your problems you can go
to school debt free you can be strategic
you can win scholarships you can go to a
tuition assistance program you can go to
a community college there are so many
ways to get educated that do not involve
debt so take it off the table there is
hope to be found and it's in the mirror
it's not in the federal government it's
not in the next bill it's not at the
White House you're not going to find it
there it's right there in the mirror and
this is the year you can start to make
progress on that debt become debt free
and we want to show you how to do that I
got out of thirty six thousand dollars
of student loan debt yeah and you can to
America you can do this but it takes
deciding that your hope is not going to
be found anywhere else but that mirror
you got this we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show well
most of you were saying good riddance to
last year because it was hard enough
just to keep gas in your car and food in
your fridge but money's still tight and
you're wondering if 2023 will be any
different guys you do not have to live
through another year of stress and worry
and that's why I want you to watch
Building Wealth in 2023 our free live
stream on January 12th because we want
to show you that you can still make
progress on your goals build wealth and
have peace with money even in this crazy
economy during the event you'll hear
from Dave Rachel Cruz George Campbell
John deloney and Ken Coleman and we're
going to talk about how to set goals and
create margins so you can build wealth
this year we're going to have some fun
and you're gonna leave fired up for 2023
guys even if the economy still feels out
of control this year you do not have to
to register for the free live stream go
to ramsesolutions.com wealth that's
ramseysolutions Dot com slash wealth
these have been fun events forward to
that I know I love a good live stream
because you got the in-person crowd but
then there's also you know hundreds of
thousands that will end up watching it
so the impact the ripple effect when you
do a live stream event it inspires me to
go I wonder what kind of debt's going to
be paid off what kind of wealth is going
to be built because of the stuff they're
hearing and the stuff those people are
going to do after the event and it's so
cool that it's free I didn't realize it
was free till this morning
events have sold out all around the
country so the fact that we're doing
this and you can just watch it for no
cost at all that's just that's amazing
you know Dave wanted to charge mega
bucks for and I said no Dave make it
free you went all right fine you're like
I'm home the line it was that easy I got
a lot of pull around here thanks for
your service don't miss this one totally
for this is a great one also to tell
your friends and family because they
don't have to put in a dime the only
skin in the game they need is to go
register ramseysolutions.com wealth and
sit there for an hour and be hopefully
entertained and inspired there we go all
right let's go to the phones next up we
have Mike calling from Milwaukee
Wisconsin hey Mike welcome to the show
hey guys how are you okay we're great
how can we help
um so I'm 15 and I was just wondering um
what the best way to research colleges
and how much I would need to save up for
college
I like the best way to do that yeah Mike
I love that you're calling in at 15
years old that's that's wonderful so
tell me what do you want to do
um I'm not 100 sure yet
um but probably either business or law
that's great and you obviously seem
motivated where did this motivation come
from at 15 years old to call into a live
National radio show and ask about
college
yeah um so my mom's been a big fan for
like the last couple years
um and I I've been listening to you guys
for like the last month
that's outstanding go mom and go you
yeah and I was just I'm curious I want
to I want to formulate my plan for the
next couple years
um I'm currently I have a job currently
and I'm bringing money so I want to
I don't want to just have it I want to
save it properly absolutely well the the
time Horizon for you to go to college I
would not go investing all of this money
and then see the market dip and all of a
sudden you have to pay for college and
the money's not there so I think your
best bet at this point is a high yield
savings account to just start throwing
as much money into that as possible how
much money do you think you could put in
every month
um probably like seven eight hundred wow
what are you doing for work
um so my main job I'm part-time uh
cashier
um and that brings in like 600 a month
and then I have side hustles that I do
what kind of side hustles
um So currently I
I in the summer I'm a Lawns but that
isn't currently working and then I do
like small home repairs
wow and like and I build like Furniture
like Ikea furniture
these are great skills you got a real
entrepreneurial Spirit to you is that
something you'd ever consider because we
just talked to yes a guy who was 20
Tanner who at 15 years old your age
started a lawn care business and is
crushing it
yeah and he doesn't have a degree so I
just want to question the the idea that
you even need this to go where you want
to go
no so I don't really want to do I don't
really want to be an entrepreneur I kind
of want to be in like business
management cool so in your ideal
scenario what what does college look
like for you where are you going do you
have a dream School what's what's kind
of your vision at this point
so at this point I really have no idea
um I have no dream school I just want to
research the best way and figure out
like how much I would need to save okay
that's great and I'm so excited about
this call because I feel like I'm
talking to myself at 15 years old like I
actually thoroughly enjoyed going to the
library and pulling out those big nerdy
college books with like the you know 350
best colleges in the country and I would
sit there in the middle of the aisle
with that book just going through every
College reading about the details of
like what was the culture like at that
school you know what's the financial aid
like what are the scholarships like what
are the different options and what would
be a good fit so it sounds like you're
super motivated and you have a wide open
range right now so I would encourage you
to take some time especially at 15 years
old to do some research you know there's
great websites um Princeton Review capex
College data where you can go online and
type in things like are you looking for
a big school or a small school are you
looking for a certain type of culture do
you want something in the city what's
the price range what's their graduation
outcomes like you can get that granular
and really look into you know what
colleges you'll be matched with with
certain parameters so I would encourage
you to start there especially with such
a broad Horizon and have fun with it
like I know I feel like I'm sounding so
nerdy but I truly enjoyed that in high
school that was one of my favorite parts
of prepping for college was just going I
could go anywhere like I could go
anywhere I'm gonna have to work for it
and get scholarships but I I could go
anywhere and it's an exciting time yeah
so that's cool and then once you once
you kind of start narrowing in on you
know some possibilities then you can
start lining up some college tours so
you can get on campus you can get there
in person you know start talking to
people maybe you can monitor a class you
can talk to their financial aid
department to see what kind of
scholarships they offer you can see what
kind of work you could do when you're on
campus you could get a feel for the
culture so getting there in person is
great plus you show the college that
you're interested and having interest in
the college could also open up some
doors for you to maybe get a waiver on
your application where you can apply for
free it may open up some doors to
Scholarships in the future so just
having that early interest can really go
a long way
do you have a good guidance counselor at
your school
uh so I'm currently homeschooled oh okay
um that's what's up I don't have a
counselor with an awesome Mom it sounds
like Mom is the guidance counselor she
sounds fantastic
um so I do have a people who Health but
don't I don't have any guidance
counselor hey you know what my mom and I
we were like rocking buddies in this
process my guidance counselor wasn't
super proactive so
um right now in public schools the
average load of a guidance counselor is
450 to one sounds reasonable right so I
definitely encourage parents to be
proactive in this process because a lot
of times there's just not that time for
one-on-one attention with every single
student so it's a great resource if you
have a proactive guidance counselor and
if you don't then the parents get in the
ring with your student and help them
figure out you know what they need to do
and Mike here's one thing to take into
account don't get emotionally attached
to one single school because if that
doesn't go through then all of a sudden
your world has crumbled and your plans
for the next 20 years have now are now
gone and so just hold it all Loosely you
have so much life ahead of you and
regardless of where you go to school
what happens Mike is the secret sauce
you are the secret factor to your
success and so it really doesn't matter
where you go to school I want you to get
further education and business if that's
where you want to go and just do it
based on where do where did I get
scholarships where can I afford to go to
finish debt free and what helps me get
closer to that dream
hey Mike did you have another question
yeah so I was just wondering the best
way to divide my income in savings
well I mean like George said a high
yield savings account can be good you
can look into esa's or 529s
um I would also just encourage you to
understand financial aid that's just
kind of a factor to look into if your
family is going to qualify for financial
aid look into the parameters with that I
talk about that in my book how to
graduate debt free because it may be
better for your mom to save it in her
name versus your name because student
income and savings is factored
differently than parental income and it
can reduce your eligibility quite a bit
if it's saved in your name but yeah 800
bucks a month three years from now turns
in almost 30 grand that's a heck of a
start man Mike you're rocking it and I
love the fact that you're calling it 15
years old y'all earlier you can start
thinking about this the better you have
time to plan and be strategic this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day is Proverbs 25 28 a
man without self-control is like a city
broken into and left Without Walls our
quote comes from Theodore Roosevelt with
self-discipline most anything is
possible love it I feel bad that's a
good one coming in in January
self-discipline self-control that is
what is needed this year that is what is
needed I love a good proverb Christina
it's like if the best version of Twitter
there ever was you know so good Twitter
I don't think I've ever heard Proverbs
compared to Twitter but that's gonna
stick in my mind now it's like just
little tweets of wisdom just little
wisdom which is not what Twitter is if
you've been on there lately
there we go oh gosh well let's go to the
phones next up we have Janet calling
from Sarasota Florida hey Janet welcome
to the show
Hi how are you hey we're doing well
what's up
um I'm calling because you know I I've
become a man seashell fan
um but I just started listening to him
late in life of course I'm 70 years old
and um in 98 I purchased my home free
and clear and it's been that way for 25
years and way to go
yeah I know but uh and so
I would I was wondering if there were
exceptions to
what kind of debt a person my age should
even entertain because I mean I'm not
really a fan of debt
I like that credit cards when my husband
passed away about 10 years ago
and um now I'm my get to ratio to income
is is a little bit high and enough to
for them to mention it to me my credit
is good I I pay my bills on time and I
pay more than the minimum amount
but I do live on a fixed income and
there's very little relief on that
um it's true no fault on my own I got
disabled in an auto wreck when I was 45
and well that's when I got the house I
was actually a little younger I guess
um
so jaina how much debt do you have time
too how much debt do you have right now
I've been a widow twice oh so sorry yeah
that's a lot that's a lot I know and
when well how I got into the credit was
it really was a lifesaver for me in many
ways because I do own a home and a home
is like a child it always needs
something
and um of course there's nobody to call
if your toilet breaks you've got to fix
it you know it's your turn so you've got
some home repairs
oh definitely definitely I bought a
house that was so inexpensive
that it didn't sell on MLS for two years
and I did on it and I got it
after looking at many many homes
and talking to many many people who
wanted to sell me manufactured home I
had cash
and I and they just wouldn't take me
seriously finally found an investor who
had a home he didn't want it was just
out of the way out of his beaten path
and he introduced me to it and I I saw
it and I said that's I told him he
already knew what I was looking for and
that was back in characteristics that's
the home you're in now
so what kind of dead do you have and how
much
oh about 16 000
in Capital One so you know I mean these
are
um cards that I I would never default on
them
what other debt do you have
I don't have any other debt except the
credit card debt
and are you considering taking more debt
right now I only got that in the last
eight years or 11 years because
I didn't believe in credit so what is
your you said you had a fixed income
what is your income every month
it's about 1700 a month
and you don't have a mortgage but you've
got other expenses how much do your
expenses what do they add up to each
month
well including those minimum payments I
usually put 800 around 850 in um
in another bank for my Social Security I
don't mix the two Banks and then I pay
my bills online out of that and then
there's a few I pay in person like um
like I'll pay my phone bill online and
my insurance car insurance online but
then I'll go right over to Target and
I think we got to stop going to Target
Janet I think that's part of the problem
we got to stop leaving the house because
every time you leave the house you start
swiping the cards right
well I kind of am good about not doing
that when I want to be
what happened what happened you said
about eight years ago you started you
didn't believe in credit before that and
then you started using credit cards what
what shifted
my husband died and he left me with all
the bills and and only half the in a
fourth of the income he had a business
that
he I couldn't run and and I just had to
I had to have some kind of liquidity
what are these house repairs going to
cost you Janet do you know
well that's that's a good one um which
ones have to be done not the ones that
are nice to haves but what do you have
to have done
um my kitchen top down my bathroom's
totally a a win free bottle
show uh bathroom winner is it time to
get out of that house is it time to just
sell it and no no now let me explain
that my taxes are under is this around
100 a year
because I've been here 25 years and I
bought a really cheap house and I can
only raise your taxes three percent over
the year
per year so I'm locked in
I cannot buy another house with this
quality so what are the repairs going to
cost have you got an estimate from uh
from a handyman a contractor
yeah well I I actually have a handyman
on site that does all the small stuff
but the contractor stuff like I need a
new electrical panel I need a roof
eventually my roof's 19 years old I paid
for it myself
I put on a 4200 roof in 2003. and it's
been through three category fours
and it's done really well I'm really
impressed with the guy's work but he's
no longer around here Janet do you have
any independent do you have any savings
or anything
um in a 401k yeah that's a good one
that's the uh
thing that I I think I'm not doing a
baby steps I'm sure because I I don't I
have like seven dollars in the bank most
of the time or 15 cents depending on
what
no retirement accounts nothing you could
sell any extra Vehicles anything to
create some money for you
my husband's vehicle when he passed
I couldn't get what I I didn't only want
to give me 800 and I and I said no I
wanted 1200 and then the deal went South
and then I didn't advertise it that was
a neighbor doing that so well Tina I
know it's not ideal
um but 70 there's still a lot of 70 year
olds who get out there and work and
hustle um can you get out and do get a
job
um well that's debatable I was in
physical therapy last year for almost a
year I couldn't stand up a walk
and so I can't do any jobs like
cashiering or what about like a customer
service role from home that you could do
on the phone anything to create some
income I have thought about that and
I've been I've been looking into it
I have the websites that I've gone on
were just like take a survey you know
and then they call you with Windows and
things they weren't really real
um job opportunities like they said they
were so I've kind of hit a dead end
there but I was looking at I thought
well will Amazon be great to work for or
somebody like that where I could do
customer service on the phone you're
right I could do that eventually you
need to have a little hope and get
creative because right now this is a
dire situation we have to get out of
this credit card debt we have to come up
with money for the home repairs we're
not going to go into any more debt for
the repairs just take debt off the table
please for the love cut up the cards I
want you to retire with dignity I don't
want you stressing about finances as a
two-time widow living alone in this
house that's falling apart this is not
the life that anyone intended for you
especially you you can still uh do this
you still could have many many years
ahead of you and you can enjoy them and
not sit there worrying about how you're
going to pay your bills on that fixed
income yeah but you definitely got to
find that margin right now because
um yeah you could have a lot of years
ahead and the fact that you can still
work I would encourage you to do it now
especially when you need to get that
house repaired so that you can when you
reach that spot that you can't work
anymore we want that house solid we want
you to have a great place to stay
all right that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show and the books if you like
the show please consider subscribing
leaving a review and sharing it with a
friend it's been a good time George good
times as always Christine a great job
thanks to my co-host George thanks to
Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew and the
booth and to you America thanks for
listening we'll see you next time this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]